why screen uh tree is he beautiful Ansel  cool three-year anniversary post about  The Fault in Our Stars I can't believe  it's been three years since that movie  yeah it's amazing it's been amazing ride  and I'm very single for that opportunity  still feel like it's opened a lot of  doors for me and gave me my first  opportunity to really tackle role and  did they ever figure out whose fault it  was  wasn't stars no like I feel like we know  what was a blame game hashtag please  father  it deserves a sequel then cuz we I don't  think your fault in your stars  you started to hang out Shailene at all  yeah I see your occasionally and she's  always incredible you could ask her next  time you see her who's possible was  she'll tell it's mine and I am in love  with you all your efforts to keep me  from you're gonna fail  [Music]